Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Bap meogeosseoyo.
(Pubblico): Bap meogeosseoyo.
MC: Bap meogeosseoyo è un saluto coreano,
molto diffuso fino a qualche anno fa.
Letteralmente significa:
"Avete mangiato oggi?"
Infatti dimostra la preoccupazione
dei coreani per la propria salute.
Sappiamo che la Corea del Sud
ha attraversato una profonda crisi,
fino a qualche anno fa;
però oggi è diventata una potenza globale
nell'ambito dell'industria,
della tecnologia.
Per me, nella mia esperienza coreana,
"Bap meogeosseoyo" è il simbolo
che le crisi non solo
si possono attraversare,
ma ci posso rendere molto più forti.
Però come si fa?
Sono anni che studio crisi,
a livello della società,
delle organizzazioni, e personali.
E uno dei motivi [per cui]
mi sono appassionato a questo tema
è [che], come si dice a Roma,
me la sono un po' cercata.
Ho cambiato otto paesi in 12 anni;
ho cambiato tre professioni,
quindi ho dovuto reinventarmi
e ricominciare da zero molte volte.
E alcuni di questi cambiamenti
hanno portato delle crisi.
Altri cambiamenti, invece,
sono avvenuti grazie a delle crisi.
Quindi oggi vorrei parlare con voi
di crisi personali,
di come attraversarle,
trasformarle e ripartire.
Che cos'è una crisi personale?
È un periodo della propria vita
dove sentiamo una profonda energia
negativa all'interno di noi,
riconducibile a un evento,
a una persona o addirittura una frase.
Nell'ambito del lavoro,
"La tua performance non è buona",
o "Sei licenziato!".
Nell'ambito dell'amore,
"Non sono più innamorato
di te, lasciamoci."
E nell'ambito della famiglia
o degli amici,
"Ho un problema di salute,
mi devono operare."
Quindi vorrei chiedere a voi
qual è stata la vostra ultima crisi.
Qual è stato quell'evento,
quella frase che l'ha generata.
Fatto?
Se ancora non lo avete trovato,
per favore venite voi la prossima volta
a parlare di come non avere crisi.
Questa è una delle crisi
più significative della mia vita.
Quello che vedete è il geyser
del lago di Ginevra.
È il simbolo della città di Ginevra.
Ma è anche il simbolo
di come mi sentivo io, a Ginevra.
Infatti stavo al top della mia carriera,
ma mi sentivo che stavo in caduta libera
nella mia vita personale.
Infatti due anni prima
ero riuscito a entrare,
subito dopo laureato,
in una delle più grandi multinazionali
dei beni di largo consumo.
Era il mio sogno ideale.
Dopo due anni ero riuscito
a farmi trasferire nell'headquarter,
nella sede europea di questa società.
Ed ero contentissimo.
Ma dopo alcune settimane,
le cose non sono andate come pensavo.
Infatti ho avuto molte incomprensioni
con il mio capo,
con cui non ci trovavamo,
era molto esigente.
Il marchio per cui lavoravo
era in profonda crisi,
quindi c'era molta pressione
all'interno dell'azienda
e non ero riuscito
ad ambientarmi a Ginevra.
E quindi ho reagito
nell'unico modo che sapevo:
lavorando più ore.
Ma le cose non sono migliorate tanto.
Infatti, lavorando più ore
ho incominciato ad avere
meno tempo libero e meno per gli amici,
ho incominciato a mangiare male,
dormire male, lavorare male,
diventavo meno produttivo
e quindi dovevo lavorare più ore.
Ero entrato in questo circolo vizioso
da cui non sapevo come uscire.
Ero arrivato a pesare 99 chili,
e a piangere, alcune volte,
prima di andare al lavoro,
tanta era l'ansia prima di arrivare.
Poi un evento fortuito, drammatico,
che mi ha costretto
a letto per dieci giorni.
E per la prima volta, ancora mi ricordo,
che non ho aperto le email di lavoro.
Quei dieci giorni li ho dedicati a me,
a capire la mia situazione,
perché mi sentivo in questa maniera.
A capirmi meglio.
E quando sono tornato a lavoro
ho cominciato a parlare
con altri colleghi
che avevano lavorato col mio capo,
che lavoravano per altri marchi
che erano simili al mio,
che avevano molta pressione,
ai colleghi inoltre, anche,
che si erano appena trasferiti a Ginevra.
Ho incominciato a chiedere loro:
ma voi come fate? Cosa provate?
E con mio stupore,
le loro risposte erano diverse
da quelle che mi aspettavo.
Infatti, riconoscevano sì la mia ansia,
la mia crisi, le difficoltà;
però loro avevano reagito
in maniera diversa.
Vedevano in queste difficoltà
un modo per imparare di più,
perché a loro piaceva il loro lavoro.
Quindi, forse, mi è venuto il dubbio
che il problema non era il contesto,
non era né il mio capo,
non era né l'azienda, né Ginevra;
forse, forse, il problema ero io.
Perché stavo reagendo in questa maniera,
perché gli altri reagivano
in maniera diversa.
E quindi ho incominciato a cercare
qual era il vero problema, la vera causa.
E ho fatto questo esercizio,
l'esercizio dei valori.
Ho preso una tabella con tutti i valori
e le cose più importanti della vita,
e ho sottolineato quelle più vicine a me,
e le ho messe in ordine.
Questo esercizio mi ha fatto già capire
molte cose della mia situazione.
Infatti, avevo preso questa carriera
anche perché mi dava sicurezza economica
e sicurezza sociale.
Il famoso contratto a tempo indeterminato
che molti italiani cercano.
Nello stesso tempo, era anche quello
che faceva piacere alla mia famiglia,
che mi avrebbe dato la sicurezza
per creare la mia famiglia.
Ma il mio valore vero,
il mio valore principale era la passione.
E alla domanda: "Ero appassionato
di quello che facevo?"
la risposta, banalmente, era no.
Una seconda domanda mi ha aiutato:
"Voglio fare il lavoro
del capo del mio capo?"
Perché come sapete, in azienda
una delle motivazioni del lavorare tanto
è per essere promossi.
E fare il lavoro del proprio capo,
per lavorare ancora di più
e diventare il capo del proprio capo.
E questo processo,
se siamo fortunati, dura anni.
E quindi è una domanda
importante da farsi,
"Dopo così tanti anni sarò contento
di fare il lavoro del capo del mio capo?"
E la risposta, banalmente, era no.
Quindi questi due esercizi, tra gli altri,
mi hanno fatto capire che il vero problema
era che non mi piaceva più
quella carriera.
E quindi ho esplorato nuove alternative,
e ho deciso di fare un dottorato.
Mi sono laureato a Parigi,
con soddisfazione mia e dei miei.
Questo mi ha portato poi
a insegnare a Helsinki e a Seul,
dove insegno Management e sono
specializzato in gestione delle crisi.
Questa invece è una
delle mie ultime crisi.
Il 25 marzo 2019, due mesi fa.
Mi ricordo bene questa data.
Stavo a letto, guardando
il soffitto della mia camera,
in piena energia negativa,
condizionata da una parte sentimentale,
lavorativa, professionale e familiare.
Quindi ho fatto l'esercizio di prima,
di capire qual è il vero problema.
Per capire il vero problema, però,
ci vogliono alcuni giorni,
alcune settimane
anche per prendere delle decisioni.
Nel frattempo abbiamo
questa energia negativa.
Non so se vi è mai capitato
di stare a letto
di non avere la forza di andare al lavoro
o di vedere degli amici.
Quindi la domanda è: come gestire
questa energia negativa che proviamo?
E uno dei motivi per cui l'abbiamo
è perché la mente, alcune volte,
è la nostra migliore amica;
ma alcune volte diventa
la nostra peggiore nemica,
come degli studi di psicologia ci dicono.
Infatti la mente va a rivivere
quella persona, quella frase
milioni di volte,
cercando forse una soluzione
che comunque ormai è inutile.
E ogni volta che pensiamo,
che abbiamo questo pensiero negativo,
abbiamo un'altra ondata
di energia negativa dentro di noi.
E quindi per gestire questa energia,
forse dobbiamo gestire i nostri pensieri.
Il discorso silenzioso che abbiamo
all'interno della nostra mente,
il nostro percorso mentale.
E questa è una tecnica che ho utilizzato,
creare il pulsante d'aiuto.
Cioè selezionare una ristretta cerchia
di amici e familiari
che sappiamo ci possono aiutare
per questa crisi specifica.
Il pulsante d'aiuto,
quindi, è una metafora,
il pulsante che possiamo spingere,
la telefonata che possiamo fare
per i momenti in cui siamo
particolarmente tristi.
E parlare con un'altra persona
ci aiuta a dare una nuova prospettiva,
e cambiare il nostro percorso mentale.
Questa volta ho fatto una cosa diversa
anche, ho utilizzato un percorso -
un pulsante di aiuto social o virtuale.
Infatti seguivo da molti mesi
due gruppi di sviluppo personale.
E ho visto che, negli ultimi mesi,
le persone incominciavano a pubblicare
richieste di aiuto
e consigli su libri o su cose,
suggerimenti per come
gestire meglio il tempo,
come gestire lo stress, come perdere peso,
come gestire un collega che non ci piace
o come andare avanti
dopo la fine di una relazione d'amore.
E quindi ho deciso anch'io
di mettere la mia domanda.
E ho ricevuto più di 120 commenti.
Il fatto che degli [estranei],
delle persone che non conosco,
avessero investito del tempo
a darmi dei suggerimenti,
mi ha fatto sentire meno solo.
Con alcune di queste persone, poi,
ci siamo sentiti in privato
e ci siamo aiutati a vicenda
a superare questa crisi.
E ho avuto anche una serie
di libri, di audio e di video
che ho incominciato
a leggere, ascoltare e vedere
che mi hanno aiutato a capire
qual è il vero problema,
e a superarlo.
Questa invece è una seconda tecnica
che ho utilizzato,
la tecnica della tavola dei desideri.
La tavola dei desideri è quell'immagine
che vedete di fronte al mio letto.
Quell'immagine è semplicemente creata
con una slide di Power Point.
L'ho divisa nelle quattro aree per me
più importanti della vita,
per voi possono essere diverse:
l'amore; le finanze;
la carriera e la salute.
E poi sono andato su Google,
Pinterest e Instagram
a cercare delle immagini
di come volevo sentirmi
in quella particolare area della mia vita.
E quindi: nella parte dell'amore,
voglio sposarmi, avere tre figli
e avere una relazione con cui
c'è intimità, complicità e gioiosità;
nell'ambito delle finanze,
voglio raggiungere un equilibrio,
la cosiddetta financial freedom,
libertà finanziaria;
nell'ambito della carriera,
ho messo tutte le riviste accademiche
su cui voglio pubblicare,
i premi che voglio vincere
come professore,
i libri che voglio pubblicare
e anche quanti follower,
sui social media, voglio avere.
E nell'ambito della salute,
ho messo tutte le immagini
di come vorrei vedermi
e di come vorrei sentirmi quando mangio.
Una volta creata
questa tavola dei desideri,
l'ho stampata in diversi formati
e l'ho messa nei posti,
nei luoghi dove passavo più tempo:
in camera da letto,
in soggiorno, in ufficio.
L'ho messa anche come cover
del mio cellulare.
E ogni volta che la mia mente
mi voleva fregare, o mandarmi nel passato,
io cercavo di fregarla e di mandarla
invece nel futuro, nei miei desideri.
Di come volevo sentirmi,
non di come mi sentivo.
E mi focalizzavo su tutta quest'immagine,
e soprattutto su un numero: 79.
Che cos'è il 79?
79 è un mio obiettivo,
l'obiettivo del mio peso
che ho da tantissimi anni.
Vi ho detto [che],
nella mia crisi di Ginevra,
ero riuscito ad arrivare a 99 chili,
a sfiorare i 100.
Però poi avevo perso
tantissimo peso, ero arrivato a 82.
Però non ero mai riuscito
ad arrivare sotto gli 82 chili.
E il 25 marzo 2019, due mesi fa,
pesavo più di 90 chili.
E quindi mi sono detto,
voglio utilizzare
tutta questa energia negativa
per trasformarla in un mio obiettivo,
l'obiettivo che ho da tantissimi anni.
E quindi riuscire a raggiungere
i 79 chili entro il 25 maggio.
Cioè oggi.
E quindi da bravo ingegnere, che ho fatto?
Ho creato un grafico, ho detto:
quanto devo perdere,
di media, ogni settimana,
per raggiungere questo obiettivo?
E sono riuscito a perdere -
intorno al 20 aprile pensavo 83, 84 chili.
Quindi avevo perso già tanto:
ma lo sappiamo, gli ultimi chili
sono più difficili da perdere.
E poi ho smesso di pesarmi
per un po' di tempo.
E oggi vorrei condividere
con voi questo momento.
Sono riuscito a raggiungere
o meno il mio obiettivo?
(Applausi)
Qui abbiamo una bilancia
che è stata tarata con i miei pesi,
con il peso dei miei vestiti.
Possiamo chiedere
a una persona di controllare?
(Applausi)
Questi due mesi sono stati un bel viaggio.
E questi sono alcuni strumenti
che ho utilizzato
per trasformare una crisi.
Il primo è chiedersi
qual è il vero problema
perché, come nel mio caso,
avrei potuto cambiare capo,
avrei potuto cambiare brand,
marchio, azienda o anche città.
Ma il problema poi sarebbe tornato,
perché il [punto] era
che non mi piaceva quella carriera.
Questo esercizio dei valori
può aiutare a superare, e a capire,
il vero problema di molte crisi.
E poi cambiare il percorso mentale,
e quindi creare un pulsante
di aiuto reale o virtuale.
E questa tavola dei desideri
che mi ha aiutato tanto a focalizzare,
a trasformare l'energia
da negativa a positiva.
Perché sapete, io so che avrò altre crisi:
non posso evitarle, probabilmente,
non posso neanche evitare
che voi le abbiate.
Però so che si possono attraversare,
anzi, si possono trasformare.
Quindi vorrei chiedervi come trasformerete
la vostra prossima crisi.
Quale sarà il vostro 79?
Bap meogeosseoyo.
(Applausi)